- This is like the best moment, ever.
(laughing)
("Carol of the Bells")
- I'm nervous to sit on Santa's lap.
I don't know what if my butt feels weird
and he calls me out on it?
He's like, "You have a weird butt.
"Get off me."
- You know how everyone
be going to the malls
with their families during the holiday
and you know, I always wanted to do that
and I never got the chance to.
- I would go to malls all
the time with my grandmother
and she's Israeli and she'd be like,
"Why do you want to sit
on a man's lap like that?"
- You know be on like some intimate level
and just like this is what I want.
This is what I really, really want,
and somebody can be like,
"Yes, it's gonna happen.
" I'm gonna make it happen for you."
Is sounds wonderful.
My heart is just pitter pattering.
- [Santa] Ho, ho, ho, ho, (laughing)
- Can I get on?
- [Santa] Oh, my goodness.
- [Santa] Hello.
- [Girl] Whee.
Oh you're so--
Oh our hearts are colliding.
I feel like we're one.
- I have a lot of respect for you
and the utmost admiration.
- [Santa] Really?
- [Man] Yeah.
- Well, I'm interested to hear--
- I think what you do is very good.
- Well, let's just put
you right down here.
There we are.
Oh, oh, I love it.
Yeah, this is perfect.
- This is nice.
I could get used to this.
(laughing)
- Hi, how are you?
- I'm jolly, you know me.
- Yeah, I've heard you're jolly.
- Yes, you have.
- Okay.
- I've been doing this for a while now.
- All right, wow.
This a first.
I like this.
This is--
- There's a little bit of magic, right?
- Yeah, absolutely.
- The only type of lap sitting
I've done is the opposite
where someone else is on my lap.
- Oh, yeah. (laughing)
- So, I just ask you anything or what?
Ask for any present or with in reason?
- Well, you know you can
just let your imagination
run wild.
- Obviously a boyfriend.
Maybe like six foot,
light eyes, lots of hair.
He doesn't you know, religion's
not a big thing for me.
- I would really like a black pug.
I really want a pug.
- You know, I'm thinking
that I'm gonna need
to get a toy shop or a pet shop
up there with the toy shop.
- Yeah.
- I would love an XBox One.
- An XBox One.
- My girlfriend doesn't
want to get it to me
because apparently it's
too violent for her
to have in the house,
but I would play it when she was sleeping
so she wouldn't know.
- The only thing is I don't
know if I can find somebody
like that and put him in the
sleigh and deliver him home.
- No, you can't deliver him to me, Santa.
If you can't get him to
me, I mean we've got FedEx.
We've got UPS.
- I'd like for just people
to be like a little more
like consciously aware of being nice.
- Exactly, that's the Christmas spirit.
- Can I take a selfie with you?
Is that possible?
- Oh, ho, ho, I love it.
- Do you do selfies?
- Oh, I do selfies, in fact we have an elf
up there at the North Pole,
we call him Selfie Elfie.
- No way.
- Yeah, his name was Beacon.
- Does he hang out with Elf on the Shelf?
- Well, he's even kind
of one of those guys.
- Okay, all right, let's do this.
- Selfie Elfie, ho, ho,
ho, Merry Christmas.